people of the internet they did it again
back to Hogwarts day 2023 and somehow
even with no new content planned I'm
looking at you Mr Chandler wood Hogwarts
Legacy somehow stole the show once again
because it turns out they did have
something new for us
[Music]
a beating heart of this franchise was
Hogwarts we knew that we needed to bring
you back home now I get what Chandler
was saying and I always appreciate when
their marketing and social teams put
info like this out there to help set
expectations they didn't want anyone to
think there was going to be a big DLC
announcement here no it's not DLC no
it's not a sequel although we do have
some news on that as well that we'll get
to here in a moment what they did
announce was a behind the scenes
full-length feature to release later
this year called the Wizardry behind
Hogwarts Legacy we also got a two and a
half minute trailer showing off some of
what we can expect from this which is
what you're seeing right now and guys
this trailer just chills from watching
this we always pull the magic out of the
hat right out at the last moment who
would you be what kind of student would
you be that was at the heart of the
fantasy that we felt like we wanted to
deliver on
thank you
this is being described as a love letter
to the fans and so many of the things
that we saw throughout the development
of this game such as the passion of
these developers working on it their
attention to detail just all of that is
evident here so all those things that we
got and the lead up to launch the
gameplay showcases the developer
interviews all those things where they
really let their passion and their
energy and excitement for this project
shine through it seems like we're going
to be getting much more of that which is
incredibly awesome one thing though now
that the game is out they're going to be
able to pull back the curtain more than
ever before so it is expected to release
later this year and one thing I haven't
seen a lot of people talking about is
just how we're going to be watching this
at first I was thinking it was going to
be like a standalone release that fans
could purchase or maybe given to all
those who ordered the game but no it's
even better than that according to
information that I received straight
from the folks at WB the full length
feature will be available free for
everyone to watch on the official
Hogwarts like it's a YouTube channel
again later this year now what exactly
do they mean by feature linked well this
can vary across the film industry and
from what I was able to find it seems
like anything over about 40 minutes
could be considered feature links so
even though I know that everybody's
holding out hope for a DLC fingers
crossed for a DLC I still think it's
gonna happen however getting something
like this in the meantime is certainly
going to be something nice and fun for
fans to look forward to now I did
mention a Hogwarts I can see sequel
rumor but before we get to that we also
have to talk about quidditch Champions
which was a complete no-show at the back
to Hogwarts Day event this was announced
back in April and so far very little of
this game has been shown at least in any
official capacity we know there have
been a series of play tests but still no
official trailer or even a release
window and anyone who has played the
game as part of one of those play tests
is actually under NDA and can't say
anything about their time playing it so
until we actually get some official
announcements official updates on
quidditch Champions things are going to
remain quiet on that front as for the
rumored Lego Harry Potter game nothing
new at all and I gotta say this one I'm
a little surprised by I thought this was
definitely going to be either here or at
Gamescom I was totally buying into that
rumor I do still think that this game is
happening maybe it's just not as close
as a lot of people were thinking and
with events like this they're always
fluid and in motion I'm sure a lot of
this was pre-planned months in advance
and then there are other things that
they were probably hoping to have that
just couldn't line up in time fingers
crossed that we're going to get some
info on that before the end of the year
we did get a few updates on the mobile
titles Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery and
Harry Potter magic awakened but nothing
at all on the console games which I
think is what most people were wanting
to see all right now what about this
Hogwarts Legacy 2 rumor all right stop
me if you've heard this one before an
Insider Twitter account that's right at
my time to shine H now this person does
have 137 000 followers I can't say that
I'm personally familiar with them
however they tweeted sources confirmed
that a Hogwarts legacy sequel is in the
works now normally I probably wouldn't
put much stock into something random
like this however this was actually
picked up by Tom Henderson of Insider
gaming who is a very reliable Insider
and I don't know whenever I hear people
say the Hogwarts Legacy 2 is in
development all I can really think is
this game sold so incredibly well and I
really think elevated Avalanche and a
lot of people's eyes because as we all
know in the lead up to launch people
kept talking about oh all they've done
is kids games and then they absolutely
did just a phenomenal job with Hogwarts
Legacy albeit there's still a lot of
room for improvement a lot of things I'd
like to see in a DLC and a sequel and
for me that is still the biggest
question is whether or not we are going
to get a DLC I think a sequel is all but
inevitable given everything that WB has
said about this becoming a franchise all
the amazing sales but the critical
reception the fan reception there is 100
going to be another Hogwarts Legacy game
where they call it something else who
knows you know there were so many people
trying to make a big deal about this cut
content from Hogwarts Legacy there was
something found in the PC code about
Companions and how that system was
scrapped from the game and I don't know
I just didn't find that as big of a
story as some people did because when
you think about it every single game is
going to have something that the
developers wanted to put in but just
either ran out of time or for logistical
reasons he just couldn't make it happen
and I still feel pretty strongly that
even though publicly they have said
there's no plans for DLC at this time I
still feel like DLC will will eventually
happen however I have to think that the
conversation has at least been floated
and mentioned what if we don't do a DLC
what if we just take all these ideas
that we have here for a DLC and instead
work that into the sequel I mean we only
have to look at one of the other biggest
releases of 2023 with the Legend of
Zelda tears of the Kingdom which as
everybody knows originally started out
as a DLC expansion to breath of the wild
so these things in game development
they're fluid they can change rapidly we
all know that all the versions were
originally planned to release on the
same day and of course PS3 and Xbox 360
got bumped and then the Nintendo switch
version got bumped where it's still not
even out yet and so now we wait for
official news and updates on what's next
for Hogwarts Legacy I certainly have
plenty of thoughts on what I would love
to see in a sequel and I already have a
video ready for you on just that subject
you can check it out on the right side
of your screen now as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon